now I'd like to welcome today's
presenter Kristin Singh money kristin is
an associate professor at Stanford
University she teaches statistics and
writing works on statistical projects in
sports medicine and writes about how
science and statistics for a range of
audiences she offered the Health column
body news for a Laura magazine for
decade and she is also the statistical
editor for The Journal physical medicine
and rehabilitation and she offers a
statistics column statistically speaking
for this journal she teaches the popular
massive open online course writing in
the sciences on Coursera she was the
recipient of the 2018 Biosciences award
for excellence and graduate teaching at
Stanford University hi so today I'm
going to be talking about how to be a
statistical detective and you might be
wondering why you'd want to be a
statistical detective why is this
important so unfortunately there are a
lot of statistical errors in the medical
literature when people do surveys of the
literature they find that a high
percentage of papers have at least one
error in either the statistical analysis
or in statistical reporting and I'm sure
you do just some of those examples here
you can see that it's really a high
percentage of papers in fact in one
survey they find found that just that 19
percent of the papers they reviewed had
just simple numerical mistakes know
these types of errors should never
happen and yet they are alarmingly
common so today I'm gonna share with you
some tools and tricks that you can use
to catch errors in your own work before
you submit things for publication or
when you're doing peer review now I
spend a lot of time doing a statistical
detective work because I do statistical
review for journals I also review papers
post publication so for example
sometimes a journalist might ask me to
vet the statistics in a paper prior to
them writing about it interestingly the
vast majority of errors that I catch are
not sophisticated they are not subtle
problems in a fancy statistical model
these are much more
it's things like you know the author's
added wrong
you can catch most of these errors even
if you don't have an advanced degree in
statistics what it really takes is just
common sense the ability to add subtract
multiply and divide and some really cool
easy-to-use online tools and I'm going
to show you three of my favorites
today's that Czech Grimm and web plant
foods advisor and then finally of course
it's also helpful to have a good
understanding of some basic statistical
concepts so today I'm gonna walk you
through three case studies that
illustrate the use of these tools the
first case study dates back to 2006
there was a paper in Nature Medicine
that garnered a lot of attention and the
authors claimed that they could use
publicly available data to identify
genetic signatures that would predict a
cell's sensitivity to specific cancer
drugs the idea was that you could use
this then to match cancer patients to
the right drug for their cure and this
was named actually one of the top six
genetic stories of 2006 by Discover
Magazine and there was a lot of interest
around this and so there were some
physicians at MD Anderson because this
was based on publicly available data
wanted to institute this or implement
this in their own institution and so
they approached to MD Anderson
statisticians keep beggarly and Kevin
Cruise and they asked for their help in
recreating this method when covered
Kevin beggarly and combs started peeking
into the method and the data however
they started to uncover a number of
problems and I'm just going to share one
example with you so this method is based
on publicly available data some of the
original data were published in The
Lancet in 2003 and what you're looking
at here are breast cancer cell lines the
blue cell lines are sensitive to the
chemotherapy drug dr. tousle whereas the
red cell lines are resistant to the drug
the authors of the nature medicine paper
used the exact same data and they
claimed that they had come up with a
genetic signature that could separate
the resistant cells from the sensitive
ones now what am I going to do
actually just take a careful look at the
top panel versus the bottom panel and
see if you can spot a problem and this
is basically like that spot the
difference game that you played when you
were a kid so look carefully the top
panel in the bottom panel and see if you
can spot the problem we've been spot the
difference and keep in mind that blue in
both graphs means sensitive and red in
both graphs means resistant if you're
looking very carefully you might notice
that in the top graph there are 11
sensitive cell lines and 13 resistant
cell lines but then the bottom graph
these have been exactly reversed there
are certain 13 sensitive in 11 resistant
what happened is that the authors of the
nature medicine paper got this wrong
they mixed up the resistant and
sensitive cells the reason this happens
is that we often code binary variables
as ones and zeros so in this case maybe
one min sensitive and zero mint
resistant but when the authors of the
nature medicine paper we analyzed the
data they cut it backwards they mixed it
up and they thought that one mint
resistant and zero mint sensitive this
is a big problem because it turns out
they ended up using this algorithm in
clinical trials at Duke University to
treat cancer patients it turns out that
this algorithm was complete but it was
not at all predictive but had it been
predictive it would have actually been
assigning cancer patients the exact
wrong drug for their tumor now this is
not a sophisticated error rate this is
just messing up what one means and what
zero means but this can have profound
consequences and it's the type of error
that really worries me um this story
this example is actually part of a
larger back story it turns out that bag
early and Coombs uncovered a whole bunch
of data manipulation errors reversals of
ones and zeros off by one errors in
Excel probably fraud as well and so it
ended up that this Nitra medicine paper
eventually got retracted along with a
host of other papers by the same
research group the clinical trials that
you were halted there were lawsuits
though this was actually part of a
larger scandal
all right the second case study comes
from a paper that I was asked to review
by a journalist and this paper was
trying to get at this idea that
sometimes when people exercise more they
don't actually lose weight and one of
the reasons is that sometimes if you
exercise more you end up compensating by
rewarding yourself with more treats and
so this paper this study was training
yet at that
so they randomly assigned 56
participants to either an exercise
condition or a fun condition the
exercise framing group there were 28 of
them walked a mile and they were told
they were walking for exercise whereas
the fun framing group they also walked a
mile but they were told that the
experiment was actually about music not
about exercise so they were given an mp3
player and they had to read some songs
after the study was over all of the
participants got out phosphate lunch and
the researchers surreptitiously measured
the number of calories that each
participant served themselves during the
lunch this table shows the main results
from the study I'm just gonna zero in on
a few items from this table so first of
all they were comparing two groups the
exercise framing group and the fun
framing group so those are the rows of
the table the columns in the table
correspond to different calorie counts
so the first column is just the total
calories they serve themselves at lunch
they then broke this down to calories
from the main meal versus calories from
the drink and the dessert and they have
two choices on dessert they could have
chocolate pudding or applesauce and the
drink was either a coke or a water
now the first finding of the author's
record actually is that there was no
difference in the groups in the total
calories serve the average calories in
the exercise group was 313 versus 305 in
the fun framing group so virtually no
difference there however the authors
really wanted to find a difference
between the groups so they kept on
digging and looking at different
components of the meal and so when they
looked at the drink and dessert calories
what they called the hedonic traces they
actually found a difference between the
groups so the average calories from
drinking dessert was a hundred and
thirty three point nine eight exercise
framing group versus ninety four point
four or five in the fun training group
and they
claimed that this was a statistically
significant difference and he actually
made a big story out of this fighting
and largely the story of their paper was
built around this result their take-home
message was see if you tell people that
they're exercising for exercise they end
up eating more sweets afterwards you
might notice right away that this is not
a huge difference right this is a 40
calorie difference so it's not a really
big difference even more than that if
you start digging into the table you
start to notice some numerical anomalies
first of all there are some curious
patterns of missing data if you look at
the exercise ramen group in all of the
columns n equals 28 meaning that there
was no missing data all of the
participants were included in the
averages for those variables however if
you look at the fun framing group for
the total meal serve there was no
missing data we're trying to eat people
but then if you look at the regular meal
the main meal in the drinking dessert
the N is 24 so we have some missing data
and this pattern is a bit curious to me
because if you have the calories the
total calories for someone that would
imply that you have measured the
calories on the individual components of
the meal now of course there could be
some innocent explanation here maybe
somebody forgot to write down where
those calories came from so they had the
total but not the individual from theirs
there could be an innocent explanation
but it does raise a red flag for me it
makes me wonder if maybe they threw out
a few data points that they just didn't
like in order to get the result they
wanted there's also a whole bunch of
miracle inconsistencies if you start
looking carefully in the table so for
example the total meal consists of the
regular meal plus the hedonic traces the
drink in the dessert in the exercise
framing group there as I said before
there was no missing data so what this
means is that the average calories from
the regular meal plus the average donut
calories has to add up to the average
calories from the total meal but when we
do a quick check of this when I add up
the 190 3.67
plus 133 point nine eight I get three
hundred and twenty seven point six five
the latter two columns here should add
up to the first column but they don't
313 is not
community 27 I don't know why he's doing
add up but they should we see a number
of other problems like this if you
speaking in the table so for example the
hedonic choices consists of the dessert
plus the applesauce so the latter three
columns here should add up to the first
column the pudding plus the apples last
course to drink should equal the overall
hedonic calories now this patient is
slightly more complicated because you
look carefully what you'll notice is
that when the author's reporting for
example the chocolate pudding served
they didn't report for all 28 people
they just reported on average among the
eleven people who took pudding how much
pudding on average did they take so in
order to calculate the average the
dominant calories per person here we
have to do a little bit more work we
have to first add up what was the total
hedonic calories for the group so the
total amount of calories taken from
tracker pudding alkalizer drink and then
divide by 28 so for example I multiply
135 point 3 times 11 to get the total
chocolate pudding calories taken in this
group plus 75 point 1 4 times 16 plus 33
point 1 29 that gives me the total
calories I divided by 28 I get 130 point
3 7 now that is supposed to equal the
first column here the 133 point nine
eight but it doesn't it's just a little
off something funny is going on here I
then took this paper and I ran it
through an online a statistical checking
tool called statue and this is a great
tool because it's super easy to use and
it does some text mining for you now it
won't work on all papers the statistics
have to be presented in the text in a
certain way but the fun and exercise
paper you can use that check on that
paper so what it does is it does text
mining and it automatically extracts
test statistics degrees of freedom and
p-values from the text then simply
checks those to make sure that they're
internally consistent so for example
let's say you have a paper where you're
comparing two groups and you run a
t-test you get a t statistic out of 1.89
and your degrees of freedom is 19 the
reason freedom is related to your sample
size a T statistic a 1.89
for the degrees of freedom of 19 that
the p-value associated with that the
correct
evaluate point zero seven four yes a
paper reports that T statistic but
reports at p-value of point zero four
five then something is wrong
those are inconsistent and Static
automatically Flags those for you
now check is implemented in our but it's
also implemented in this convenient web
app that doesn't require you to know any
programming at all and it takes about
one second to use this all I did here
was you just upload your paper so I
uploaded a PDF of the fun versus
exercise article and then it runs in a
second scans the whole article extracts
the statistics from the text and checks
them for consistency so I'm showing you
here the result that I got there's
actually more I've cut the screen a
little bit there's more results that it
flag but we flagged a number of the
statistics from the text as inconsistent
and so I'm gonna just show you two
examples of the statistics that it
flagged as inconsistent so first of all
one of the things that pulled out of the
text was this S statistic of two point
seven nine eleven the authors had
recorded that that corresponding to a
p-value of less than 0.05 which would be
considered statistically significant at
the 0.05 level snap check says wait
that's supposed to be that F statistic
is supposed to give a p-value of point
one zero one so something isn't matching
pair well I dug into the paper and found
out in the text we're we're did that two
point seven nine one F statistic come
from and it actually corresponds to a
comparison that we've already seen today
which is of these hedonic calories the
one hundred and thirty three point nine
eight hedonic calories in the exercise
group versus the ninety four point four
five in the fun group and this is that
result of the authors made a big story
up so when they need that formal
statistical comparison they got this F
statistic of two point seven nine they
then reported though P is less than 0.05
and then we've slipped in something in
the text they don't put this in the
table but they certain in the text here
this little bit of a sleight of hand
they say actually we're not reporting a
two-tailed p-value here we're reporting
a one-tailed p-value now there's
actually new reason to report a
one-tailed p-value here and in fact most
of the p-values they report in their
paper they report the two-tailed p-value
the reason they are not matching the
p-value from stat check however is the
one tail
it was half the two-tailed p-value so
the correct p-value really is point one
zero one or four but what they did is
said well we really want to get that
p-value below 0.05 so we're gonna
instead of reporting the two-tailed
p-value if we're gonna report the
one-tailed p-value and then they've done
a little trickery with somehow rounding
down because of course half of 0.1 0
should be equal to 0.05 but they're
somehow saying that that's less than
0.05 this is bad statistical practice
making statistical traces just to get
your p-value to be less than 0.05 that's
something we call pea hacking and that's
bad science now there's one other
example that they flag that I'm going to
zero in on here so there was another a
statistic of 2.83 the authors of the
paper reported that the p-value is point
zero four that check says nope that
p-value should be point zero nine eight
to nine right again dug into the paper
to see where this statistic came up in
the paper and it correspond to another
comparison that the authors made they
asked the participants to rate their how
exciting they found the walk or walking
activity on a scale from one to nine
where nine means extremely excited and
they found that the fun group rated the
excitement as an average of seven point
one nine which was a bit higher than the
exercise group which rated it at six
point four or five when they made a
formal statistical comparison between
those two means that's where that s F
statistic of two point eight three came
out but notice they're making the same
little trick as before they report the
p-value as point zero four because
they're reporting the one-tailed p-value
again there's really no reason to report
the one-tailed p-value here they're just
doing it so they can claim he is less
than 0.05 all right I then took that
same caper and ran it through another
one of my favorite online statistical
checking tools this is a tool created by
James tethers and Nick Brown and what it
does is it Flags impossible mean values
so let me just give you an example
imagine you've got a variable that
you've measured on an integer scale
so maybe you asked your participants to
rate their King on a zero to ten integer
scale and imagine also that you have a
small sample so maybe you
sample size of just 10 if you have an
integer value in a sample size of just
10 there are only certain being values
that are possible if you sum up 10
integers and divide by 10 then the mean
has to contain an even 10 so you can get
a mean of zero point zero zero or four
point one zero but you cannot get a mean
of four point one or four point one five
so if the authors reported mean of 4.15
then you know something is not quite
right this has been implemented in both
web app as well as a phone app they're
very it's very easy to use all you have
to do let's take your meter and your
sample size from your paper enter it
into grim and it's gonna tell you
whether or not that mean is possible me
so I went ahead and I entered that one
hundred thirty three point nine eight
average donek calories from the exercise
group the end there was twenty eight I
entered that integral I tried various
ways of rounding and they all in all
cases it tells me that one hundred
thirty three point nine eight is
inconsistent meaning that is not a
possible mean if calories were measured
as integers and I have a sample size of
twenty eight now there is a possible
explanation there we normally report
calories and integers and if you look at
calorie counts on a food label they're
always going to be an integer values it
is possible that when the researchers
here recorded the calories into the
database they recorded calories out to
one or more decimal places that could
therefore cause the mean to be a hundred
and thirty three point nine eight so
that's that's possible however remember
we've already looked at something in
this paper that we know for sure was
measured on a major scale so the
researchers asked the participants to
rate how exciting they found the
activity on this Likert scale from one
tonight and this is definitely need your
values and remember the results here was
that the fun condition had a mean of
seven point one nine and the exercise
condition had a mean a six point four or
five and I can tell from the degrees of
freedom in that F statistic that there
was no missing data used in calculating
those means all 56 participants were
used in that comparison meaning all 28
per group were used in calculating those
needs so I can run this through the grim
checker
when I do that I put in seven point
right nine and sample size of 28 lo and
behold it tells me seven point one nine
is inconsistent it's not a possible
meaning and again I tried all versions
of round being formalized and tried
different person surrounding it's
inconsistent in all cases same with when
I put the six point four five and 28
into grim also tells me yep
these this mean is also inconsistent so
this paper just has a lot of red flags
in it and it actually has a back story
as well so the reason that I was looking
at this paper for the journalists is
because one of the authors of the paper
has actually had 18 other papers
retracted now this particular paper has
not been retracted but the author has
had a large number of papers retracted
due to the same kinds of problems
numerical inconsistencies sloppy data
handling peacocking so we might not be
surprising that we're seeing so many
problems in this particular paper he was
actually the inventors of the grim past
Nick Brown and James heather's who
actually uncovered a lot of the problems
in those papers that led to their
attractions alright so the first two
case studies I showed you were actually
tied to a long larger likes handle of
scientific misconduct I just want to
show you that the majority of her such a
catcher not tied to some larger stand
also this third case study is just a
study I happen to come across there's
one finding in the study that I think is
not robust so I'm not criticizing
anything else in this study and it's not
tied to eat a larger scandal this was a
study that happened to get some press
attention last year it was a study on
breastfeeding and stress in babies so
it's well known that breastfeeding
reduces stress in babies in the claim of
this paper was that the authors had
found a genetic mechanism that explained
how breastfeeding might lead to lower
stress in the babies and there were too
many findings the first finding was they
looked at 41 mother infant carers and
among the babies that were breastfed
they found lower DNA methylation of two
genes related to stress and DNA
methylation is a way of regulating gene
activity that was a first finding the
second finding was that they then
correlated this lower DNA methylation of
these genes with lower stress in the
babies where stress reactivity
that second finding that I'm gonna zoom
in on that so the authors actually
published a plot in their data that
shows the correlation between DNA
methylation of the gene and low and
higher stress reactivity and so what
you're looking at here the x-axis is the
amount of DNA methylation of the
glucocorticoid receptor gene which is a
gene involved in stress the y-axis is
cortisol reactivity which is a measure
of this and stressed in the babies the
authors reported a correlation
coefficient here at 0.41 which would be
considered weak to moderate correlation
and it was statistically significant if
you look at that plot you know it does
look like it seems like as the
methylation goes up the stress
reactivity goes up it looks like there's
some association here it's important to
understand though that when you
superimpose a straight line on a graph
like this it can be misleading to the
eye and so what I did was just to pup
this particular graph into just
Microsoft Paint and I sort of cruelly
erased that line and when you look at
the graph without the line you get a
different impression so let me go back
here it is with the line the line is
kind of drawing your eye in a certain
direction when you take the line off or
because appearance is that Association
doesn't look so strong anymore but we
really have is just kind of this one
cloud of points down here and in that
cloud of points it doesn't look like
higher methylation really correlates to
higher stats but then we have this one
data point up here Todd this one baby
who happens to have both high
methylation and high stress reactivity
and the concern here is that at one
point might be what we call an
influential data point that one point
might be drawing the line toward it and
causing us to see an association that's
really not robust and so I wanted to
prove these data further and I used a
tool but in my favorite online tools I'm
reviewing papers because most times when
we're looking at papers the authors have
not provided the underlying raw data I
wish they would but in a lot of cases
they have it webpart digitizer gives you
a way to extract that underlying raw
data from plots or images in the paper
and so for example
if you have a scatterplot like this the
each of these data points corresponds to
a methylation level and a stress
reaction level that XY coordinate is
what web plot digitizer can extract a
webpart digitizer extracts the XY
coordinates and each one of these points
near by recreating the underlying data
set giving you back those methylation
levels and those stress levels it puts
it in a CSV file that you can then
download for further analysis
so this is super cool and useful it's
quite easy to use it's implemented in
the online app I was able to download
these data from web digitizer in about
under a minute and I have a little demo
video that just shows you how easy it is
to use this particular tool to use web
plug digitizer go to their website
upload the image that you want to
extract data from then you have to give
some information about the scale of the
axes so you click on two points on the
x-axis and two points on the y-axis and
enter those coordinates and now you're
ready for data extraction to use the
manual data extraction you simply click
on all of the data points that you see
on the screen and once you've hit all of
them you then hit view data and now you
have a data set that's ready for
download into a CSV file that can be
used for further analysis so you can see
that super easy to use and what I did
was I took that data set i extracted the
data and web plot digitizer again it
took me less than a minute and you don't
need to know any coding or anything
super easy to use and then I just
verified that I was able to reproduce
the original analyses that appeared in a
paper so I popped my data into SAS what
you see on the right here is my
reanalysis I'm able to regenerate the
same basic plot and I also get an R a
correlation coefficient of 0.4 one
exactly what the authors reported my
p-value is point zero one they report EP
is less than 0.05 so it's a good match
this just verifies that I extracted the
data correctly once I know that I've
extracted the data correctly then I can
do some reanalysis so I did three things
so first I've already told you that a
straight line can be mislead
to the eye so I removed that straight
line and I superimposed instead what's
called a loez life and this allows a
little bit of curvature and can better
reveal the underlying patterning in your
data
I also calculated what's called a
Spearman correlation coefficient rather
than our standard Pearson's correlation
partition the Spearman correlation
coefficient is based on ranks rather
than absolute values and therefore it's
less susceptible to influential points
and then finally I repeated all of the
analyses removing that potentially
influential point so I could be just how
much influence that one point was having
on our analysis all right so when I took
that influential point in I just the
original data set same data set haven't
changed anything and I just superimpose
that loez line rather than straight line
and you can see that that laura's line
sort of shows me you know there really
isn't much going on for most of the data
points but that line is being drawn by
that one point upwards the Spearman
correlation coefficient here turned out
to be much lower than the Pearson's
there was point for one and now we're
seeing a correlation of only 0.18 which
would be considered very very weak
correlation it's no longer statistically
significant if I remove that influential
point what you'll notice is there's
basically no Association left we have
now mostly a flat line but whether the
correlation coefficients are about point
one which would be considered minimal
correlation values they're very high in
other words there doesn't appear to be a
lot going on here
once we remove that one influential
point that entire Association was really
driven by that one data point that one
baby who happen to have birth high
methylation and high stress reactivity
now it could be that if we were to
sample more babies in sort of that area
of the graph with very high methylation
it might be that those babies would also
have high stress reactivity and that
this association would hold but as it
stands now we are basing the entire
Association on one data point and it
could also be the case that it just
happens to be by chance that that baby
happens to have both high methylation
and high stress but that those two
things are not acid associated so if I
were reviewing this paper what I would
have told the author's to do is to show
some of these additional and
and also you can moderate their
conclusions accordingly
alright so my take-home messages for
today are statistical errors are common
in medical studies now some of these
errors may have new consequences they
may be very minor but others can
completely undermine a study's
conclusions a lot of these errors don't
take an advanced degree in statistics to
catch and I've given you some tools that
you can use to catch these errors of
course when you can rather prevent these
errors from occurring in the first place
rather than have to catch them after the
fact and so the way that you prevent
errors is to follow best practices in
statistics principles of effective
statistics and these are the kinds of
things that I teach in my course so for
example if you're gonna be analyzing
data the first thing that you need to do
is to check and understand your data you
need to know what one stands for and
what zero stands for you should
double-check that and triple check that
in fact most of a data analysis is spent
in this step checking and understanding
your data and one of the common errors I
see when I students company or
researchers come to me with data they
come into my office and they've got some
output from a statistical analysis
program they say oh can you help me I
understand what this output means and I
say okay well let's go five steps back
you know what have you done to clean
your data to check your data to graph it
make sure you've checked that there
aren't any funny data points and a lot
of times people have to skip that stuff
they're really really happy that they
were able to get their data into a
statistical analysis program and then
something came out yay and they skip the
most important steps of the data
analysis which is where you're merging
data checking data making new variables
cleaning data understanding what you
have in your data set and in fact when I
do a data analysis I said 90 percent of
my time doing this this depth 90 percent
of my code will be about checking and
understanding the data and you know
making new variables and so on so that's
really most of what happens in a data
analysis you also want to pay attention
to simple numbers so make sure that your
ends add up and that simple numbers in
your paper add up draw lots of pictures
with your data it's always easier to
understand what's going on with your
data if you graph it news
in cents it's a funny thing about
statistics that often people start doing
statistics I think they're so
intimidated by it that they prove common
sense out the window so just go back to
the basic common sense consider the
totality of the evidence so don't just
cherry-pick then one or two tiny results
that seem to support the story that you
want to tell really understand what the
data are trying to tell you keep an
accurate record record of all your data
manipulation and data analysis encode
please please please do not manipulate
data or analyze data in excel it's very
easy to introduce errors in itself
that's actually what happened in that
case study with the nature medicine
paper that I told you about earlier you
want to port your data set into proper
statistical analysis program like SAS or
R or Stata and anything you do to the
data merging the data making new
variables you want to do all of that in
code and keep an accurate record this
don't actually helps you to prevent
yours it also helps you to trace back an
error if an error ever occurs finally if
you're gonna be analyzing data it's
important that you understand the basics
of probability and statistical inference
this doesn't mean that you have to be a
whiz in linear algebra or calculus it
does mean though that if you're gonna be
analyzing data you ought to understand
some very basic concepts like what is
standard deviation and what is the
hundred error it's a pet peeve of mine
that there are a lot of people running
around analyzing data that don't know
what standard error is even though
that's like a column that comes out in
every single one of your statistical
outputs through understanding those
basic concepts it's really important in
being able to get things right and
interpret things correctly so to help
you to do better statistics and to
follow principles of effective
statistics I have a few resources I want
to point out so I've been writing a
column for the journal p.m. NR for over
a decade now there's the probably 35 or
40 columns at this link
they cover some basic concepts and
statistics but also some more advanced
topics so like if you want to learn say
about principal components analysis or
instrumental variable analysis I may
have a call on line on those things I am
also as of today launching a new
online training program medical
statistics one two and three you can
earn a certificate in medical statistics
if you complete all three courses so
I'll just say a few words about those
three courses I'm really excited about
the new program so each one of these
courses is four units long
they'll take you about 15 to 20 hours to
complete and will be teaching you
programming in either SAS or are you do
not need to have any prior knowledge
about souther are you can have never
opened SAS or before and that's just
fine we will start at step one we will
be using the the free version of SAS SAS
the University Edition or you can use
are you do not need to do the courses in
further those you can just take one of
course you're welcome to do in both the
course is implemented in both languages
in med SATs one you will be learning
that introductory programming
descriptive statistics data
visualization and also principles of
effective data analysis med snaps to
goes through the basics the foundations
of statistical inference probability
what is a p-value what it's Bayesian
inference common statistical pitfalls
and also when my favorite things to
teach which is computer simulation and
just to give you an example of how power
powerful computer simulation is there is
a classic probability problem called the
birthday problem and it goes like this
mmm if you have 30 people in a classroom
and you ask what's the probability that
two people are gonna share the same
birthday not the same you're just the
same thing turns out that most people
think that's going to be pretty low and
it turns out that that probability is
actually 70% surprisingly high now you
can solve that birthday problem with
probability with permutations and
combinations really fun problems to
solve mathematically I'll show you how
to do it but it's a little complicated
you can also say it solved that same
problem just using computer simulation
which is much easier much more intuitive
few lines of code and all you do in a
computer simulation is you have the
computer randomly select 30 birthdays
out of the possible set of 365
birthday's imagine you had a big dice
number 365 sides and you just roll that
for any times come up with 30 birthdays
and you check to see if there's a match
and then you have the computer do this a
large number of times me a hundred
thousand times your computer will do it
in a few seconds and you just see
frequently for their matches how many
classrooms out of 100,000 had a match
and that's your probability it gets you
the same answer is the mathematical
solution but it's much easier it can
also solve more complicated problems so
for example if I ask what's the
probability that three people share a
birthday that's hard to solve
mathematically we just solve on a
computer and so then mixed outs three
will then cover specific statistical
tests for different types of data that
are common in the medical literature as
well as Fox the Guru those statistical
tests and regression analysis and so I
think I'll open things up now for for
questions and answers on my talk and on
the courses thank you so much Kristin
for the informative presentation we'll
go ahead and take them to any questions
now I continue to submit your questions
via the Q&A box there and all and you're
from Kristin so the first question here
is for the exercise test what rule does
sample size play if at all in the
validity of the study so these questions
about the fun and exercise paper
yeah the sample size is not huge here
that 28 per group it's not it's not the
worst I've seen but it's not huge and so
obviously the more people you sample the
more precise your answer is going to be
that is you're going to have a better
sense of the of the answer and if you do
very small studies what you can show is
that if you have studies what what we
call underpowered and you can show that
when you find in the literature
significant results from small studies
those significant results are more
likely to be false positives than if you
had run a study that was properly
powered so there are really good reasons
to make sure that you run properly
powered studies which usually mean is
having a big enough sample size and
that's one of the main concerns with
small today's it's easier to find
something just by chance in a small
study and then we tend to you know
specifically significant we make a story
out of it those studies are more likely
to turn out to be false positive so on
the next
question I believe this might be related
to the fun creaming activity did they at
least justify why they were using a
oneself so I again this paper has a lot
of red flags I think it's time to an
author who has actually had taken an
early retirement from poor now for these
reasons they did not in fact they don't
even mention in the table that it's a
one-tailed p-value they just kind of
slip this in in the text and there is no
justification
most of the p-values reported our
two-tailed except for the ones that they
wanted to get under 0.05 and suddenly
it's a one-tailed there's no explanation
anywhere in the text if I were doing a
review of that paper in peer review I
would have told them to explain that
choice and maybe they had an explanation
but my suspicion again given the larger
context here is that they were simply
trying to get the p-value less than
right Oh 5 when there is a small sample
size and a strong or highly significant
p-value is shown
can we rely on this value and some
people state that the results are very
strong if there is a highly significant
p-value with such a small sample
yeah so one of the the problems in the
medical literature is we have put too
much emphasis on the p-value and people
read too much into a few value I'm not
taking that camellias are useless or
that they're bad it's just that they are
one tiny piece of information along with
a list of other information that you're
supposed to look at and unfortunately
sometimes people think too much
attention to the p-value now it is true
that the smaller the p-value that's
indicating something about about your
results and so if the p-value is less
than point zero zero or one versus less
than point zero five you can show take
some other assumptions that you have to
work you can show some things like it's
less likely to be a false positive so
you can have more faith in the idea that
maybe that's not a false positive if the
p-value is much lower but there's a lot
of factors that go into determining
whether something is a false positive it
depends on how well the study was
powered and some things like this so you
don't want to just pay attention that
p-value you want to take paint into the
entire context of your study was there a
likelihood of by
setting healthy brews the study was it
well powered um you know it we could get
a really big difference between two
groups for a number of reasons that
don't have to do with the troops
actually being different in the real
world so that you know yes if the female
is less than point zero zero one I'm at
least gonna be less worried about chance
fluctuation but I might still be worried
about all these post of other things
that could have gone wrong and we always
want to pay attention to the effect size
in study design in different words or
contexts you got was just that one
little piece of information the next
question is how do I know the proper
sample size for my assembly that's a
great question so before you do a study
you should always do a sample size
calculation um it's great to work with a
statistician on that to make sure you're
doing it correctly and the idea there is
first as you before you do a study not
only to get the sample size right but
when you do a sample size calculation
that forces you to figure out what is
the purpose of my study what is the
hypothesis that I'm trying to test what
is my primary outcome in my primary
independent variable if you set those
things up ahead of time who are much
likely less likely to end up doing some
bad statistical practices where you're
just taking things out of chance
fluctuation so we always want to
understand up front before you do the
study what is the research question what
are you what are your main primary
hypotheses and then you use that
information to do a power calculation to
make sure that you have a properly
powered study and unfortunately you know
a lot of times people don't do that and
that can leave problems so another
question is why and do simple
statistical errors sometimes pass
through the peer review process that is
a great question a lot of the herbs I
showed you today should never have made
it through peer review that's fun and
exercise paper I know how I made for
peer review there were so many red flags
in that one I think you know the peer
review system is is the best system
we've got I think it's better than not
having peer review but unfortunately
it's imperfect you get a lot of people
volunteering their time they don't
necessarily have the time to vet every
number in the paper and sometimes they
don't feel confident in their ability to
vet those numbers and so things get
through that that shouldn't get through
um there are journals to employ
statistical reviewers so I do
statistical review for some journals and
as a statistical reviewer it's nice
because I don't have to pay attention to
everything about the paper I can just
hone in on those numerical values that
helps me to just to uncover some of
those errors whereas if you have to pay
attention to everything about the paper
the study design me the wording you know
there's and how important was the
question then sometimes you lose track
of the numbers so I you should we you
know did better in peer review but you
can only spend so much time on a paper
and checking every number is often not
what other reviewers are able to do it
would help if authors provided their
underlying raw data but unfortunately
there's that still not common in medical
studies so besides the tools that you
describe today that you mentioned are
your favorite are there other tools that
you can cancel sure sure I mean I use
SAS or are a lot because some of the
things like this that checker to check
that things are internally consistent
I can also pop that statistic and is
that and his house or are in check it
there
what's that check is doing and checking
your t-statistic and your degrees of
freedom to see if it matches the p-value
yes you were paper that you want to
check he's not set up on a way that it
feeds through stat check nicely there
are online calculators that actually you
can just plug in the t-statistic and
it'll tell you the p-value so I end up
using a lot of online calculators
there's also online calculators that
take summary data so you can take the
means from a paper and the sample sizes
and the standard a or things that are
two standard deviations things that are
typically given a table of the paper you
can plug those into these online
calculators like there's online t-tests
and then you can check to see if the
authors got a p-value that matches what
you get so there's a lot of online tools
that are really useful if you can move
around a little bit and happy to you
know if you want to follow up and ask
more about doesn't pepitas and other
links around so the next question is how
do we know if we should remove
influential points
in fact the important data that reflect
abnormal happens yeah so that's a great
question so one thing is a common
question I get asked is is it okay if I
remove this point I think it's an
outlying value I want to take it out of
my dataset so we never just remove data
so first of all we're not gonna we're
gonna throw that data out what you're
gonna do though is you're gonna present
two sets of analyses one that includes
that data points and one that doesn't so
that you can show the reader hey this
data point is having this amount of
influence on my results and then the
reader can interpret accordingly so the
example with the baby that one baby was
really the entire story and like I said
it could be that if you had more babies
sampled with that high of methylation
you would see the same thing but you
want to let the reader know this is
really due to one data point and so it's
important to actually run two sets of
analyses we call that a sensitivity
analysis you're gonna show both sets of
results I'm about to conduct pilot
trials for my research on biofeedback
what can be the effective sample size
that I can take in there - right so
pilot studies often are hard to know the
correct sample size because you are
doing this study for reasons other than
to show whether or not the outcome is
efficacious usually a pilot study is
done simply to test the procedures of
the randomized trial like that you know
that your randomization works that
people are going to be randomized
correctly that people will actually
enroll and actually finish your study so
it's really more about feasibility and
also to get some preliminary data that
could then be used for a power
calculation for a larger study so you
know you can do some kind of power
calculation for a pilot study but often
pilot studies are more guided by your
logistical constraints and that's okay
because you're as long as when you
finish that pilot study you're not going
to draw any conclusions about the
efficacy of the drug or the intervention
rather you're gonna take that
information and use it to do a bigger
trial should every study use modeling
generalized mixed models yes okay that's
a good question so um not necessarily
you know
you can have a really great study that
is purely descriptive so I I don't mind
a study that just gives me means if
that's that's that's useful information
this is the percentage of people that do
X that might be really useful
information and this is one thing when I
get students coming in with data and
sometimes they don't know why they
collected that data I say maybe what you
were after is just something descriptive
and you can even you know calculating
p-values or comparing groups you just
want to have some understanding of you
know how many I do a lot of things and
athletes how many women athletes are
doing X Y or Z and that's totally fine
so not every study even needs to have
inferential statistics like formal
comparisons at first if it's a very
simple study and a t-test will do is
there a reason to use something more
complicated well a t-test is just a
specialized case of linear regression
for example if I'm reviewing a paper and
you use the t-test will I say you have
to use linear regression now they're the
same test and one is one is a little bit
simpler to interpret so if it's
appropriate a simple test is just fine
there are lots of cases though when I'm
reviewing papers where I will say you
know a more sophisticated model would
have helped to deal with some of the
issues in the paper like missing data
clustered data there's lots of cases
where those more sophisticated models
are actually useful I'm changing
predictors things like that can be
handled in the more sophisticated model
how reliable for meta-analytic purposes
you consider the webpage editor
oh I know a lot of people use the web
part digitizer for meta-analysis
actually so that is one way to get the
data if it's only available in a figure
I think it's it's very reliable I think
there's actually been some studies I
don't know any numbers on but that will
cut digitizer has two modes you can do
it in the automatic mode and you can do
it in the the one where you actually
have to click on the points now the
problem with the automatic mode is it
will put dots on extremists things on
your graphs if sometimes you will have
to go through manually and like remove
those so that you might use the
automatic mode in a combination of the
manual mode to make sure that you're
getting those right but I found it to be
quite the fidelity is quite good with
the underlying data and so yeah I know a
lot of people use it in meta-analysis
how can we choose an appropriate
correlation plus among pearson Spearman
right so and so Pearson's correlation
coefficients has more assumptions you're
assuming that you have normally
distributed data like I said they are
that that statistic is sensitive to
influential points and so if you have
skewed data things that don't follow a
nice bell curve or outliers extreme
values then it's more appropriate to use
the Spearman correlation coefficient and
you can usually see that graphically if
you graph the things and it looks like
there's a few outlying points where
things are very skewed then you're
better off using this pyramid you can
always calculate both and if they are
drastically different it makes you think
usually that's because there is
something violating the assumption of
the Pearson's correlation coefficient so
human genome is big data what are your
thoughts about statistically associating
genes with clinical symptoms yeah I mean
it's an interesting question there's
been a lot written about this because we
have all this great genomic data we have
to be very careful of genomic data
because there are lots and lots of data
points and if you have 30 patients and
they each have 10,000 data points from
their genome you have to use statistics
that account for this what we call
multiple testing the fact that you have
you're comparing so many things that
you're going to find some things that
look different between the two girs you
have to be very stringent on what you
consider a difference so there are
techniques for that in genomics it is
easy to find spurious results in some of
the early results like for example with
microarray analysis that came out people
everybody was correlating microarray
gene expression with diseases and a lot
of that turned out to be spurious we
have better methods now I think there's
more quality control and that we know
how to do that better statistically but
Joy's have to be careful when you're
dealing with the small number of
patients and a large number of variables
as you would get with genomics if we
have significant outliers in a stem
finding small sample size should we take
them out of the statistical analysis and
why did you rerun the analysis without
proceeding before high methylation and
stress yeah so I mean the thing on
Ehlers is you never ever
want to throw up data there like you
always want to check look back if you
can and make sure it's not a data entry
error because that happens do but if
it's a real data point it's just
something where you have somebody that
was different than the other data point
never gonna throw it out so we never
throw out data but what you are gonna do
is you're going to run two analyses one
with the data point and one without it
so that you can see how much influence
is that one data point having may be the
case that depending on the exact
configuration that that one day
appointment actually not have a lot of
influence on the analysis in the case of
that baby that baby was having a lot of
influence on the analysis news of the
Association was due to that one baby so
then you have to interpret that in the
correct with the correct caveats that
hey we're putting a lot on one data
point but you want to do the analysis
both ways you don't want to you don't
want to only show one of those analysis
what are some programs or initiatives
that the medical field or other fields
are implementing to address the
reproducibility crisis and you know we
have evidence about which initiatives or
interventions are more effective yeah
that's a great question I mean there's a
lot of ideas so here at Stanford we have
the metrics met a research center with
Johnny and Eva since the Friedmann who
are very have a lot of ideas about how
you can improve the system the system
needs improvement and really a lot of
these things are system-wide um some
things that people think might work is
pre-registering studies for example so
if you before you do your study you
actually put down what is the hypothesis
I'm trying to test what is the research
question here's how I came up with a
sample size here's what my primary
outcomes are then you're kind of bound
to that and it prevents a lot of these
there are statistical shenanigans that
can happen after the fact where people
are doing key hacking and stuff so
pre-registration of studies is one
publishing your data making your data
publicly available it's an issue in
medical studies because we worry about
privacy but there are ways to diiie
identify data and make that publicly
available that would go a huge way to
solving a lot of the problems in the
reproducibility crisis because then it's
easy to try to reproduce analyses and of
course a lot of this could be solved by
better statistical thinking we really
need to do a better job in statistical
teaching and not teaching people that
statistics is some kind of cookbook that
you just you know provide a few buttons
and
really have to do that our teaching
should we be particularly wary of a
medical statistical study where data is
too sweet as opposed to continuance oh
that's an interesting question
I mean some things are discrete in life
and so not necessarily a lot of things
are measured discretely and sometimes we
take continuous variables and we make
them discrete statisticians will we
would rather have the data as continuous
and we're always going to try to push
you to keep it as continuous but there
are reasons sometimes valid reasons that
you might dichotomize or break something
up into categories it's in medicine we
often meet binary decisions right so we
have algorithms that say if the patient
has this VMI there these if they can we
make these algorithms and so sometimes
you're doing studies that are that are
using and testing those algorithms and
therefore it makes sense to use those
categorizations we want to be a little
bit careful about just taking continuous
data for new reason and categorizing
what I have a so we're going to
necessarily be more suspicious you might
be suspicious though why did the author
you know chop the data this way are they
are they doing something funny but yeah
sometimes things are appropriate as a
discrete variable I think we have time
for maybe one more question so how
compelling is real world being diverse
with controlled setting data what should
we watch out for in real world data
analysis okay so I think the question is
asking a real world data being just data
that you would actually collect in a
study versus play data that I might give
you in a class I'm not sure or I'm not
sure if they're asking about
observational data versus a randomized
trial so I'll try to address those so at
you know real world data are great
because we're learning you know in the
statistical class I will often give
datasets are a little bit you know
cleaned up easy to use just for learning
when you deal with real-world data that
you have gotten from a real study there
are all sorts of issues that you have to
worry about missing data data entry
errors and things like that so it's
great practice to get real data set to
work on and so that's one thing the
difference between like observational
data versus a randomized controlled
trial you can have data
there are so - there's there's pretty
good issues in both of those you have to
worry worry about like controlling for
confounding and things in observational
studies all right so I think that's all
of the question that we have time for
again you'll see on your screen and
button to learn more about the medical
statistics program and enroll in the
courses I know we've gotten a lot of
questions about how to enroll or you can
go to online dot Stanford new for is
slash medical - 606 to learn more about
this program thank you for joining us
I have you found today's presentation
helpful we encourage you to share the
recording with your friends family
colleagues or whoever might find it
useful thank you all for taking the time
and join us today and have a great rest
of your day